we begin with the Fox News Alert title
42 I'm checking my watch is coming to an
end and we're bracing for a tidal wave
of illegal immigrants the administration
is prepping now for a mass release of
Border crossers from overcrowded
facilities this as President Joe Biden
says he is streamlining the immigration
Prague process attack Caroline Shively
begins our coverage live from El Paso
Texas where Caroline just in 17 hours at
midnight tonight it all changes
absolutely Brian Steven Ainsley we're
here at gate 40 along the border wall in
El Paso it's only four at local time and
it's pretty quiet here but just behind
that wall and the razor wire are groups
of migrants and they're just waiting
here's what you'll see come Dawn
migrants huddle together from Central
and South America some begging border
patrol agents to let them in in
Brownsville 800 miles from here Fox
captured video of Texas National Guard
members blocking migrants from crossing
the Rio Grande into the U.S Jackson's in
a special task force have also deployed
razor wire migrants have set up a tent
city on the Mexico side of Brownsville
more than ten thousand migrants were
caught illegally trying to sneak over
the Border Tuesday alone republicans in
Congress want more agents and more
resources but the White House says the
GOP is the problem
would like to do more he had he's using
the tools in front of him but Congress
refuses to act instead many republican
officials want to make a political case
out of this they're not looking to meet
us at the table to actually deal with
this issue they want to turn this into a
political stunt
Smugglers have told many of the migrants
that come tonight when title 42 expires
the border is wide open the Biden
Administration says that's a lie and
anyone who wants to come to the country
must do it legally
you have to fully fund the border
security efforts the purpose what we're
doing now
is making real immigration more
streamlined and moving direction that
people know that there's a legal way to
get here and not a legal way
shelters are already filled if
non-governmental organizations are over
capacity the Administration has
authorized safe Mass releases of
migrants to city streets that decision
is in line with the 2022 memo uncovered
in legal proceedings by Florida attorney
general Ashley Moody last year Moody
says in part DHS plans to stand down as
title 42 expires and hundreds of
thousands of migrants storm the
Southwest border now the migrants we've
talked to aren't sticking around El Paso
we were just a block away from a bus
station and for 95 bucks you could get
to Albuquerque or La the folks at the
Greyhound station downtown say they're
seeing seeing many migrants head to New
York and Chicago Brian Steven Ainsley
back to you here they come Caroline um
so do the migrants from what you
understand on the other side of the
Border do they understand that when
title 42 goes away they're going to
bring back title eight and if you try to
get into the country illegally you are
excluded from coming in for five years
do they understand that
no absolutely not they're not watching
the news they can't even get on the apps
their news source is coming from the
Smugglers coming from the cartels and
they are saying look title 42 it's over
at midnight just come on in the gates
are going to open so they are very
confused when they arrive they see the
razor wire the Border agents and hear
this information a lot of confusion on
both sides of the Border all right
thanks Caroline appreciate it so let's
look at title 42. uh it's going away
title eight is there but uh who knows
because they're over the system is so
overwhelmed they're not even getting
people do you know where you already
have over 500
000 well over 500 000 gotaways that
means they're not even stopping to check
in and say sign my name the app is a
joke uh Tick Tock now has put out a
video that's been viewed 96 million
times it says title 42 is over you
cannot be deported so let me ask you
what message does that send I'm coming
I'm coming now the only thing stopping
them and build malusion providing that
video is that Texas special forces that
they put together it's not even the Lone
Star it's beyond that they have uh uh
their own air they don't own crab
carrier but they have owned their own
airplanes they're out there trying to
hunt down people and tell them to go
around to turn around uh meanwhile the
president United States admits it's
going to be chaotic from to uh from two
days ago but mayorkers will have a press
conference today at 10 o'clock and say
everything is under control
so Asylum rules these are the Asylum
rules they've been tweaked any claim
that hasn't been logged online first
you're rejected you can't come to the
country title eight to your point Steve
if you're caught sneaking into our
country you will be deported they say
right that means you as an illegal
immigrant can't apply to interlegally in
our country for five years does anyone
really buy that that's going to happen
no they don't it was outlined in a memo
in 2022 that that was discovered by
Ashley Moody down in Florida and top
border officials have now authorized
this if CBP and the ngos can't hold the
migrants they can now be released at bus
stops and gas stations grocery stores
and elsewhere they're suggesting that if
they do release them release them near
like a bus station or a place where they
can have transportation it's just it's
just a disaster
um and so I'm glad uh Caroline pointed
out that the cartels are the ones
pushing the message hey at midnight you
know they're going to open the door and
you can go on in and uh obviously that's
going to not going to be the case but
what the administration wants is they
don't want this image that you're
looking at right here where those people
are you know they've they've risked
their lives to get to the United States
and then uh there at the top is a bunch
of razor wire and they can't get in they
want people who want to come into the
country to use the app and apply at
these Regional centers apparently the
Department of State is going to open a
hundred Regional centers around the
world where if you want to go to the
United States you've got to do it
legally
you know we've been talking about the
one BP app or uh CBP app and apparently
it's been such a disaster they're going
to come out with a new scheduling app
later today so that what happens there
doesn't happen after tonight and it's
just exactly the same way as maybe the
federal government should not be in the
app or or website business because
remember when the Affordable Care Act
went online and that was a disaster
millions of people tried to go on they
couldn't do it well now there's a new
app coming for the folks down south the
Lisa Obama tried to fix it uh they've
been waiting forever they said they're
going to set up ports of places in
Colombia and Guatemala it's not ready
yet and those places where people can
apply for admission to our country
they're called embassies we already
built them I'm pretty sure they're done
so that's the normal situation in New
York to give you an idea how this is
flooding into our cities it's not just
making uh are the border cities third
world in New York uh there's over 60 000
people have come through the system
thousands going to pour in we could have
a hundred thousand in New York City and
mayor Adams says I don't take this
lightly but we temporarily suspending
the policy surrounding timing for
placement they're saying they're not
playing facing people in shelters
anymore and the surrounding counties in
New York are saying we're not Sanctuary
we're not taking any of them and in
Rockland they had a judge ruled you
cannot unload your bus at any hotels in
that county so this is because Biden has
no policy for the federal government New
York is fighting with each other Biden
was here in the city last night it took
three hours basically to get from one
place to the next the whole upper east
side
yeah gridlock you could not move they
shut down all of Fifth Avenue he's there
for a fundraiser up on Fifth in the 90s
somewhere and then you're looking at
these images you're like you're there
fundraising with you know drinking your
wine or whatever with all your friends
and this is happening Down On the Border
we need a leader who cares about this we
need someone who's going to be strong on
this President Trump was the one who was
building the wall who was trying to end
all of this illegal immigration and he
was interviewed surprisingly on CNN
yesterday on this town hall listen to
what he said about what's happening on
our Southern border
tomorrow is going to be a day of infamy
you're going to have tens of thousands
of people pouring into our country
you're going to have millions of people
pouring into our country right now at a
level that nobody's ever seen before
these people are sick anybody that wants
this to happen to our country they're
destroying our country and this should
not be allowed to happen how they're not
going to do a version of title 42 or my
title 42 which was tough if people are
sick and have infectious diseases and
lots of other problems we don't want
them being into our country we have
enough problems right now we have
problems like we've never had in the
history of our country and see that's
what title 42 was designed for if people
were sick with covid to turn them around
of course it ends at midnight what
happens after that tune in tomorrow you
can't touch the former president's
immigration strategy if you are the
Biden people you can't even bring up
Trump with a straight face because the
last year was 400 thirty thousand people
and he thought that was too many you've
already let in 1.2 million this fiscal
year with 550 000 gotaways which is a
rough estimate and always a low what we
know Brian and the first story in the
New York Times today why is it that so
many people are coming to the Border you
really have to do a story on that
they're talking about unemployment being
the reason are you crazy this isn't
about unemployment this is no this is
not about communism or socialism this is
about my God I have a chance to get into
the best country in the world for free
and won't have an appearance ticket for
10 years that should be your three line
story in the New York Times I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis